[Music]
the youngest billionaires on the planet
haven't been alive for three decades but
that hasn't stopped them from amassing
three comma fortunes
12 people under the age of 30 made it
onto this year's world's billionaires
list including four stanford dropouts
two food delivery magnates and a
cryptocurrency whiz
together this rarified group is worth
25.8 billion dollars and represents just
point five percent of the
2668 billionaires forbes found this year
clinching the title of world's youngest
billionaire for the second year running
is 19 year old kevin david lehmann worth
2.4 billion dollars the list's only
teenager inherited a 50 stake in the
german drugstore chain dm druggery
market from his father an early investor
in the business but neither are involved
in its daily operations
four billionaires under 30 all self-made
are newcomers this year richest among
them is gary wang age 28 the co-founder
and chief technology officer of
bahamas-based cryptocurrency exchange
ftx joining wang is 27 year old ryan
breslow worth an estimated 2 billion
dollars who dropped out of stanford to
build the lightning fast payment
software company bolt before stepping
down a ceo earlier this year
rounding out the new entrance are fellow
stanford dropouts pedro franceschi and
henrique dubograss who vaulted into
billionaire ranks when their corporate
credit card startup rex hit a 12.3
billion valuation in january the
brazilian-born founders aged 25 and 26
respectively are now worth an estimated
1.5 billion dollars apiece altogether
there are seven self-made billionaires
under 30 on this year's list
outnumbering the five heirs to
established fortunes that's thanks in
part to stanley tang and andy fang both
29 who co-founded the food delivery app
doordash in 2013.
their stakes were each valued at over 2
billion dollars when the company went
public in 2020 and while their stock has
dropped off since then the two are still
worth an estimated 1.2 and 1.1 billion
dollars respectively
austin russell who became the world's
youngest self-made billionaire when his
automotive sensor firm luminar
technologies went public has also seen
his fortune slide now 27 russell's net
worth is down one-third to 1.6 billion
dollars it's been a mixed year overall
for this elite cohort while there are
two more billionaires under 30 this year
than 2021 this group is collectively
worth 3.7 billion dollars less than last
year's group due in large part to choppy
equity markets and sam bankman freed's
graduation from the under 30 ranks after
turning 30 in march
benkman freed co-founder and ceo of ftx
alongside gary wang was the richest
20-something last year at an estimated
8.7 billion dollars